[Applause]
thank you for that introduction uh and
thank you all for being here today um
yeah i'm anusha um i'm here with my
colleagues vincenzo and patrick we're
data scientists at tesco
and today we are here to talk to you
about training object detection models
with small data sets
so
the primary motivator for this session
here today is that data so annotated
data that you need
is very expensive
and even more so in the context of
object detection so here we are to share
some ideas some techniques that will
hopefully come in handy when we're
trying to solve this challenge
yeah so first a little bit about
sorry
yeah a little bit about tesco i'm sure a
lot of you have heard of us um we are a
retailer uh in the united kingdom and
central europe and we are the largest
supermarket in the united kingdom we
have over 3 500 stores and over 300 000
employees
and
what this means for us as a data science
team is that there's large volumes of a
variety of data that we have access to
and we're trying to use that to help the
business
so
at tesco the data science team is quite
big and we are well established so we
have a diverse portfolio um and we have
a lot of data scientists across multiple
locations working together and yeah
these are just some of the domains that
we assist the business in
okay so the tutorial today will be
structured as follows um so first i will
begin by taking you through the basics
of object detection
then vincenzo will come on and he'll
share some thoughts around how to select
the best data set for the task and then
padraig will come on and help us
understand
how do we actually get our models to
learn from the data that we have
right
so to start off with
um yeah so in the image that you see um
say you just want to identify the
presence of a dog
what is the probability that there is a
dog in the image so that is a
classification or a recognition task and
it is relatively simple
but what if you want to
know where exactly in the image the dog
is
so that is what we call the detection
task so it's a combination of
localization and classification
but
wait there's more dogs
and unfortunately the universe is vast
and there's more than just dogs so
there's lots of different kinds of
objects and
multiple instances of that and this
becomes a challenging task
so what this boils down to is three
questions
so is there an object
where is the object and what is the
object
now for the human visual system this is
a trivial task like we can look at
images and identify it without any
hassle so
for computers it's not so instinctive
and that is the challenge that we're
trying to tackle here
so
um when you talk about um working with
images it's more helpful to think of
representations of images that encode
some of the details in it rather than
the raw pixel values
and the way that you go from these raw
pixel values to those representations
earlier that used to be through some
handcrafted features say um edges
or corners gradients in the image and
then some classical machine learning
techniques um
but what many of these methods had in
common was that they were not as
efficient
um very slow
and also beyond a certain point
they reached some saturation in terms of
accuracy as well
but then came the big breakthrough so
in 2012 when alex net first came out
it was a classification network that
broke all records on the imagenet visual
recognition challenge
that was when
convolutional neural networks really
started showing their metal in terms of
computer vision tasks
so after that a lot of research has
occurred many paradigms have come up we
suggest some of the ones and yeah we'll
go into a little more detail
on some of these
so just a quick refresher on deep
learning um
so you have your traditional neural
networks they have multiple
fully connected layers where each neuron
is connected to every
neuron from the previous layers and what
you could do is
use an image consider it a vector of
numbers and pass it through the network
but you can see i mean an image
is different from a vector so it's a 2d
input and there's a lot of spatial
information that you lose when you do
this so that's the reason
convolutional networks
really
were helpful in this task because they
encode that spatial information into the
feature representations that are learned
through the network
so a little bit about convolutions so
you have an image it's a matrix of
numbers you have a kernel or a filter
that's another matrix of numbers and
every kernel has a receptive field so it
looks at a certain region in the input
and it goes over that and you it's a dot
product between two matrices essentially
and you have a response of the filter so
you would expect the filter to have a
higher response when there is a certain
pattern in the input in a certain place
and a lower response in the area where
that pattern is not found
so in that manner we can consider
filters as learning different features
from the input image
and you can have multiple filters like
this where each one of them is
responsible for different feature and
usually what we do is stack these in
several
layers and this is like the building
block of
cnn
and
you can see that
these
as you go through the network
in terms of spatial dimensions uh it
goes from higher resolution to lower
resolution when you look at the feature
dimension the number of channels
that there is an increase in that so
you're learning a lot of different
features and for example this again this
is um
of some of the feature um the the
filters from the alex net that i
mentioned earlier
um so this was from the very first layer
so they are very interpretable so you
can see some filters have learned to
identify edges of different orientations
and others have um recognized blobs of
color
as you go deeper into the network they
usually become less interpretable than
this
so now um so a filter is
a matrix of numbers so how do you choose
these numbers i mean setting them by
hand
defeats the purpose of these networks
what you want to do is set them
based on the data learn them from the
data
so if you consider
the model to be a function that has
several parameters
and you define loss to be the difference
between the
um the output of this model and the
actual correct output and if you try to
visualize the laws in some dimensions uh
this is
something um that you'll see so
if you start with a random set of
parameters you would end up on a random
point on the curve and your objective
here is to minimize the loss so minimize
the difference between the output of
your model and the actual output of that
you know to be correct so
this is done through a technique called
gradient descent um and the model sees
data and it knows which direction to
move on the curve so as to minimize the
loss and this happens iteratively until
it reaches a minima and hopefully that's
our optimal
solution
so just building up some intuition again
for the object detection i mentioned
earlier that it is a combination of
localization and classification so just
looking at the classification problem or
what you could do is take a data set
like the one you see
of images that are very tightly cropped
around the objects in them and train a
simple classifier network on them
and in the next stage where you actually
have a bigger input with several objects
you could take a sliding window you can
move it over different regions in the
image and at each stage pass that patch
to the network that you trained and ask
it yeah what do you see at this
particular stage you can use different
sizes of windows
different strides for
coarse grain fine grained
recognition
but
i mean at every stage if you have to
make a forward pass through the entire
network you can imagine that it's quite
computationally expensive
but luckily as we've seen before the
convolutions that we have all of these
are modeled as big matrix
multiplications so you don't do this
sequentially but in parallel uh the
convolutional network takes care of this
across the image
so
when you think about how object
detection models are built um so
typically any convolutional network in
the initial layers
it acts as a feature extractor so it
learns these rich representations of the
image
now working with these
there is a class of models called two
stage detectors so it very closely
follows
the idea that i described earlier of
having these windows that you look for
the object in
so in the first stage the network looks
at the feature maps and it tries to
answer the questions is there an object
and where could the object be
so you have those red boxes that you see
on the feature map on the right
are these are proposals that the network
makes yeah possibly there is an object
here and what the second stage of the
network does is look at each of these
different proposals
and tries to classify what object could
there be in that and also refines the
location on it
of it a little bit
so where exactly is the object and what
is the object but then
later came another paradigm of models
called the one stage detectors in which
this two-stage pipeline is not present
anymore
and
the detection head that's responsible
for
locating the boxes and classifying them
directly works with the feature maps and
not with any of these proposals that
another intermediate layer has to make
so
when one stage detectors came they
really offered a very lightweight a
faster solution to this task of object
detection
it is worth mentioning that two stage
detectors are more accurate at
localizing objects and even at
classifying them but um if you have any
limitations say you want to run it in
real time your go to would probably be a
one stage detector because it's just
faster
these are some of the popular
architectures under each kind
we look at one of them called the yolo
it's a one stage detector in a little
bit more detail
so
jolo v3 um
v3 does indicate that it came third in
the series of the yolo family of models
and yolo stands for you only look once
not you only live once
um
and what that means is that
you only pass
the image once through the network and
you end up with the boxes as well as
the classification for each box
so the way this is done like there's
obviously a lot of implementation
details but i won't get into
the complete detail of that on a very
high level uh it looks at the image as
a grid so there's several cells
and each cell of the grid is responsible
for
detecting a fixed number of objects so
every
cell always tells you that there's
three possible objects but of course
there's a score associated with each of
it which it learns from the data that
you can use to filter out
and
uh it looks at the entire image to make
every detection and all of the classes
are detected in parallel but there's
also an associated probability map that
you use to get at the final detections
this is just a diagram of the network
um so yolo has this great feature where
the
the features that it learns are in a
hierarchical manner so if you can see
for the
first stage when when you look at the
small objects that it detects so it uses
feature maps that are quite downscale
so very small feature maps but for the
next scale of detections the feature
maps are up-sampled but they're also
combined with
higher level features learned from
earlier layers and both of those are
used to
make detections at a medium scale
and similarly for larger objects as well
so you have these three different scales
of detections associated
yeah so coming back to the three
questions that we asked in the beginning
um so is there an object
the obj this is the output of the model
and the objectness core in the middle is
the answer to that is there an object
then where is the object so you have the
box coordinates and what is the object
you have the class scores
so uh the way yolo is built again
so i mentioned that every cell always
predicts fixed number of objects right
so there could be many uh predictions
for even the background areas where
there is no object uh but the objectness
score again takes care of that you can
just set a threshold there and say just
throw away everything below that and
everything above that could be an object
but there are cases where
say if the object is very large or if
it's
present close to the boundary of a grid
cell there could be multiple cells that
predict the same object and both of them
could be quite high in confidence
so
how do you actually get from that
on very noisy output to the clean output
so
before we get to that i'll introduce one
um common
metric that to be aware of in
the context of object detection
so
in the images that i've shown here
if you consider green to be the ground
truth box and
red to be the prediction
which would you say is a better
prediction
one on the left or the one on the right
on the middle
the right
yeah yeah that makes sense for us right
so
the detection quality increases from the
left to the right
and just mathematically speaking um
we have this metric called the iou score
or the intersection over union
so it it is a measure of the overlap
between two boxes in terms of their
intersection and union
and if you calculate those for the boxes
shown
you would see that the one on the right
has the highest
iou out of all of them
so
typically what you could do is if you're
trying to make a choice between these
three boxes
you could say a threshold and say that
yeah everything below i don't know say
0.8 is bad about 0.9 is good
it depends it depends on your
application and this is commonly used
also in um to measure the quality of
detections or later on when you're
trying to associate the ground truth up
to the predictions across entire images
so coming back to the earlier problem
of post processing the output
if you have multiple high confidence
detections around the same object and
you want to understand how to get rid of
them
an application of the intersection over
union
is that
so say you have three boxes here
what you could do is
find the most confident out of all of
them
then find the overlap of the other boxes
the iu score of the other boxes with
respect to the most confident one and
again threshold depends on your
application um say you choose 0.6 or
something everything about that if
there's an overlap get rid of those
you just end up with the one box um the
most confident box and the it's most
likely to contain the object exactly in
it this is a technique called
non-maximum suppression and it's used to
get rid of duplicate detections
sorry
um it could be in some cases that
there is there are many many objects
quite close to each other but also
you can't really threshold it um across
the entire image because
they could be smaller objects that are
lower confident
right but um
if you use a global score threshold of
say 0.5 but smaller objects are
predicted with 0.4 but there's a lot of
small objects presented there and you
know that you don't want to get rid of
all of them but in the vicinity you want
the most confident one
so yeah
okay so before we go on to the
challenges again are there any more
questions um about what we discussed
okay so yolo for speed over accuracy
um again
yeah they are considerably uh the two
stage detectors are considerably more
expensive so it depends i mean if you
want a system that's very accurate but
not necessarily running in real time
maybe you want to run some offline
experiments then you can still
use the two-stage detectors
and also again the yolo that i mentioned
so yolo v3 came out in 2018 so in
yeah yeah there have been many there's
been xrf a number of letters appended to
yolo um
so four years is a long time in this
field and a lot of models have come out
the reason we chose to speak about yolo
v3 here is that at the time it had a
number of improvements that really
offered the sensible trade-off between
accuracy and
speed so and it's a relatively easy
architecture to understand so that's the
reason you're using it here but yeah it
depends on your application really what
you choose in the end
i would say that is a little tricky
small objects um
it does tend to miss it because when you
look at a grid um every grid proposes
um say
three objects but then you only end up
choosing one
but there could be multiple tiny objects
within it and that is a shortcoming of
the yolo you could use a more granular
grid um divide the image into many
smaller parts
and expect an improvement in the small
object detection
anything else
okay um if there's nothing else
a little bit about the challenges that
we face here
so
in terms of um the data set itself
uh we could just end up in a case with
very few images so you have too little
data then the model cannot reliably
learn from it
um again you could have very small
objects as was brought up which is
always a challenge
and it's it's always you experiment and
you try to find out what works best
or they could be occlusions in the data
set where objects are not fully visible
but you're still trying to identify them
or
just plain old class imbalance where you
have
more examples far more examples for a
few classes and not as many for the
others
or there could be high intra class
variance which means for
say you have the class dog but you have
many different breeds of dog in that so
just a lot of variants and which is a
difficult problem for the model
or again in terms of just how the data
is collected or
what cameras you have access to varying
viewpoint illumination and several other
factors that you'll have to account for
so this is on the data side and again on
the model side so if you're trying to
develop a real-time system it could be
too too big too slow to run
and
you'll have to take all of those into
account so especially on the data side
um so
the next thing that we're going to see
vincenzo is going to talk you through it
is to see how
even when you have little data how do
you actually choose the best
data out of that so you can gain the
most insights from it
yeah that's me so thank you
and vincenzo will be on now
[Applause]
okay
assembling a diverse dataset
yes as anusha said um objective action
model are great models
with great performance
but have some kind of issues most of
those are related to the data
and so it is important in particular in
industrial setting create a good data
set
in particular industrial setting uh
differently from the academia we have a
lot of data
i think for example to
the cameras they have uh many frames but
most of those frames are that are images
essentially uh are almost identical
and so are almost useless
and
the second point is that
something that
[Music]
to get to take into account is that we
need level uh to annotate those images
and annotating is quite expensive
so it is a fundamental task
to identify what is an informative data
set in order to select the
correct
images to annotate and then to train the
model on that
uh yes
in this presentation
so i'm talking about creating the most
informative dataset to try to identify
what is informative the problem is
mostly related with objects is related
with object detection but in general to
any machine learning model and as it is
related to any machine learning model
the idea
is to utilize a very simple
example
uh just to have a picture in our mind
and impossible to generalize the
principle that i'm utilizing here uh to
different other contexts so let's
consider just a
function
and that goes uh from
r to our just the single dimensional
line
if you want to
think from an image perspective i think
the x-axis like
the image features and the y-axis
uh the semantic
uh properties of that
of those images
for example if we are in object
detection setting there are only two
classes
the y-axis could be the difference
between
objects in one class of one classes
minus objects of the other classes
positive means that there are more
objects from the class a and negative
means that there are less classes over b
and what we should avoid is to sample
an uninformative
dataset like the one on the right as we
see
if we sample only the some particular
points the one in the interval minus
five five
uh we obtain
something uh that is not
quite informative because in that case
the the
infer the function will be just a
straight line that is not the real one
uh
yeah one thing that i didn't mention
obviously the constraint is
that we can sample only a small amount
of data point we can evaluate this
function in a small data point the
evaluation is
the equivalent
equivalent function of annotating the
images
okay
in order to avoid that
that's we sample only in a small
interval standard approach is
saying okay i have all my videos
and i simply
i will sample randomly
the frames from the video but
that it that works only under the
assumption the data is uniformly
distributed in my videos that is not the
case
and in general in most of our life we
see that most of the data are almost
identical so sampling or uninforming the
image we will have a situation like that
where essentially we have again a
straight line plus an outlier
this this will be considered liar if we
can see only those 20 data points
so it's not useful
but
we can see from this example that all
the points are concentrated
around the
values minus minus 5 5 in the x-axis and
are very close
the distance
is less than 0.5
so one idea could be just okay i remove
the
closed data points
is that possible
yes it is time
and one way is
utilizing the hashing map
those particular
map is just a function that goes from
the image space to
a string space
a binary string space
and this idea is com the opposite of the
standard rushing maps where we want to
find a single signature for an image
that
is different from any particular image
but actually here is a signature of a
kind of similar images
in order to do that
we have first to
remove the noise in image
rescale those in order to have
to consider only the aggregate
information and then banalize and
convert it to the flood function
now i will show that
good question the question is how to
remove the noise
i will use it as a notebook
yes here you have the image the same
data set of this kind this player c
monitor
and
we convert to tensors because
essentially
everything will be done with by torch
and first way
first idea is
to remove
the colors so
our image is just some matrix
a set of metrics with three different
channels and the
red green and blue
and the idea is to uh map everything
into a single channel
uh
for the sake of this talk everything
will be done
via convolutional layers that is a
convolutional map that are the ones that
anusha previously explained essentially
most of the thing in computer vision can
be described in terms of
convolutional maps
and
in this way we have to define a special
convolutional map
that
is just a matrix one times one with the
width
of three essentially the idea is to map
each pixel with the three channels into
a single one
uh
here we have
some parameters that are the kind of
size as i said the length of this matrix
the stride how much i have to move
because
uh as an usher show
the
uh
a kernel mapping is just a function that
moves from the top
left of the images to the top right
and the stripe is how much i move and
and the padding is not relevant is how
much i add on the border of the image
yes and this is a way to
reduce the information because a little
bit i want uh to get the global
information
of the image itself another
uh way to remove the noise is to apply
gaussian filter what is noise noise is
a particular information that is only on
a single pixel
so gaussian blurring is doing itself to
the opposite is associating to each
pixel the information of the pixel
around so in this way
we removed noise that's
because all the pixels uh around the
noisy pixel will have the same
information and all the pixels we are
sure that all the pixels will share
common information this is a way to
remove the noise
it's not the only one but in general is
to apply those kind of scanners
in order to share the information
in the gaussian kernel
the idea is that
the point in the center
should have the highest value that means
i have to get the most information from
the re the actual pixel and slightly
less information from the
pixels as i
uh the standard deviation define how
much information from i want
from the far pixels if i select a very
small standard deviation means that i
will have
no information so would be just the
identity market tricks
matrix and
instead if i select infinity
or yeah for example it's larger
i will have a uniform essentially would
be the mean
this is the case for example that is
infinite
and so here
we have a new
metric uh
an image where
i remove the possible
added noise
a second approach is rescaling as i said
i want global information so i don't
want an information from a pixel
perspective but aggregate those pixels
how to do that again with a
convolutional neural network
the difference here is that i like a
kernel a bigger kernel because i want to
extract more information from different
pixels and the stride
larger in particular in this case kernel
and and stride at the same dimension
that means that
each new pixel
will be obtained from different pixels
essentially there will be no
intersection when
the two metric circles and so we've done
a smaller
image to be honest that is done also for
computational reasons
uh in order to compute the hashing map
and then binarize just
uh
okay
if there are no questions
uh
yes please
i just don't see why using conversion
layers to do these configurations
definitely yes the yeah it's just for
the purpose of
yeah it's not a conversion network
they're not learned
those convolutional layers are it is
just to to show that you can utilize
all the processing in machine learning
can be done by a convolutional layer
that means that in principle a deep
neural network can learn also these ones
are not something that
is something that you can learn also so
in principle a deep neural network if
needed you can learn that
and
it was done also uh to try to explain
very quickly how convolution works
[Music]
any other question
ok
ok that means that
i have an image of simonetta and a
corrupted image of the same player
and where i just added noise and we see
that
the ashima is exactly the same that
x we said that is the same
and when it is the same means that i
mean distance
that means the difference in the string
space is zero this is a completely
different image the pizza one
will have a larger distance
so
we can say that pizza
is different from the
player image
and
obviously corrupted image
in this way we'll have a way
to have a more diverse data set
because we learn
uh
a local metric distance
essentially we are able to identify what
clause means
uh
yes and this is
the same setting before where uh with
the cross are defined at the points that
are considered close to other
ones is that enough obviously no because
as we see here there are two points that
are far
different from the
stun
straight line
but only two points are identified
as close that means that if i resample
the data don't considering the very
close points i have for sure a better
function but it's still difficult to
identify the real function that we've
seen in the first slide
so
uh
it's still incomplete but we learned
one important thing
that is
uh that a concept of distance is from uh
is
fundamental and if we
would be able
to define a global definition
of this and not just a local like the
actual map would be perfect
in particular because defining a magic
in my
image
space
means also that we can sample
equidistant data
so equidistant data
are
data that describe completely a function
or if i have some kind of extra function
for example i don't want to have points
with the y value
lower than a certain quantity or for
example i know that
in certain area
there are images of classes in which
i'm not interested in
i can remove that and sample more on the
classes where
that are more relevant for my tasks
so
we see that the concept of learning a
magic in my latin space or in my image
space is fundamental to learn
uninformative datasets
okay
is it possible to learn a magic
yes
it's possible at least according to the
deep learning theory
indeed
according to
the uh the standard assumption deep
learning the planning are working
because they are learning
a hidden uh representation of the data
that's
uh is
that
lie into a manifold manifold it's just a
surface or a line in
in dimension in many dimensions and
there it's possible to identify some
kind of similarities for example in this
image
we see
a
representation of the books
and
and we see that similar books are
clustering together
obviously
it is to mention that the kind of magic
that we the network learned
is learned in
unsupervised way we don't say
what is close the network is learning
a peculiar magic so different networks
are learning different metrics for
example
if i utilize a
self-supervised
network to learn the features i will
have a task agnostic
representation vice versa if i utilize a
supervised
model i will learn
a task specific representation so
a metric that is useful for that
particular task
indeed the concept of informative
is a task related informative something
could be informative
for a specific task but not informative
for another one
and vice versa
so uh
according
to
that point and
remembering that our goal is to find an
informative
data detection
the idea here is utilize upper train
model on a standard
dataset for example coco
that is public available
and utilize that kind of data that kind
of model
to learn a representation
for our particular task
in particular we utilize the same model
this backbone that is only the feature
extractor
that is called darknet that is the one
utilized in yolo
and the other already
explained
is a
uh yeah it is accepting three different
kind of features
one thing
to mention uh before i move into the
notebook
is that
i said it is a manifold the latent space
when the latent space is particularly
large
for in this case with at least 500
features
a common assumption
is that the data is the is distributed
around an upper sphere just a sphere in
larger damage
and
in
and as we are interested on the
difference
between the features
the idea is
to project
the points into the closest sphere
and compute the euclidean distance this
is called cosine distance
and because you can think also like just
compute the cosine
between the two points with respect to
the origin
uh
yeah
uh so that
i think it's time to move
to the notebook
yeah
we have a model
and
obviously as i said the
model is a general
objective vector model this in
particular
is
a euro
model
and we are interested only on the
background
and
and we want to extract the information
from the image the same images above
and
as expected we obtain three different
ones we see that
those
the last two numbers are the dimension
of the
latin image let's say in this way
and those are the channels
in the standard image space
those are the dimensions of the image
and those are only free
the rgb here are more because
those are semantic information
larger are the
um
deeper we go
more are the kind of features
and the smaller is the
this kind of latin image in particular
we will focus only on the third
and last feature
uh that's what we see
is
512
features
here the idea
is exactly the opposite of what we did
for the achievement in the map we want
to remove
the inform
the image specific information
so we did an average on the channel
yeah i said we want to extract the
information about the features
that are something close to the semantic
information of the image itself so the
idea is to do
uh never
in
yeah
never in the
in the image space
and that as i said could be
described also as a convolutional
this kind of
particular average kernel
is just an average
pulling
average essentially i move from
a tensor that add
512
20 20
22 22 to
500
512.11
so it's just a vector
of features there are more no more
special information stored at least not
directly
not
explicitly
um
the
and
this is uh the idea so in if in the
hashing map i did uh i tried to
do an average in the channel here i do
an average in the
space
uh
yes and
that
could help to identify
uh
sorry this kind of 512 features are the
description of our data point
this kind of description
could allow us to define some kind of
magic
this is similar to the
what we've seen with the
with the books
and we see that similar images for
example images of
with a
are close together
images with pizza are close together
giraffe images are different from each
other
and
yes
and more or less it's possible to
identify
some kind of similarities we've said
obviously that those kind of differences
are not
maybe
if we do manually we should select a
different kind of weights those are land
by the model and we don't know for which
reason the tennis player is so close to
a pizza evidently for the model they are
related
and this can be seen also in uh
in this larger picture
where there are
all the distances
and we see that essentially
uh here at zero is when the difference
is uh less than 0.3
and we see that essentially those are
the geography images
those are the pizza images
and those are the all the players images
and more or less it's possible to
identify the squares and if there are if
there are no black
anyway the difference is close to 0.3 so
that belongs
it's possible to identify some kind of
cluster
something strange is that
for many pizzas image
there are no black points okay there is
only one with
themself why that's let's have a look
too many images
many pizzas because there are pizzas and
people
so
it doesn't belong in the pizzas cluster
and neither in the
people class
it's something separate it's something
in the middle
uh so the metric somehow is working
obviously this is
only a small
sample of images
but i hope that
they
works
ok
just
concluding
and
i do a summary
we have some webserve that informative
is a
task information
but can be defined as a diverse
the uh
if i have a diverse data set this is
more useful because i'm storing more
information
this is uh something uh related to the
more general idea of entropy
and sampling uniformly
is not enough in particular in real
cases because our data originally is not
uniformly distributed
and
in order to have a good data set we
we need to apply two different stages
first of all remove the almost identical
data points
that is done by dashing maps identify
clusters
as we've seen learning the latin
manifold
via deep neural network
and
let me stress that the two points are
necessary
because
we say that the clustering is important
for
learning
mapping into latin space it's important
to learn the distance but we've seen
that are two kind of different distances
and
the
clustering images is not perfect when we
to deal with the noisy images or very
similar images indeed if we consider
again
uh the images of this football player
we see that the for dashing distance
they are essentially the same but for
the cosine distance the resistance is
0.30
essentially
according to the
distance in the latent space
the other one is just another image of
the same class
that uh
is not something that we want so the two
steps are fundamental and
the order should be first the action and
second learning the cluster once we
learn the cluster we can sample
uniformly within each data set
each cluster and if we know inform we
have some kind of information for
example that some kind of cluster is
associated to some
uh
semantic property that in which we are
not interested in we can discard this
kind of cluster but
simple only really a few of those
okay
say that
we have seen how to
what is an objective vector
how to create a data set so the next
step is really
[Music]
to
learn
train an objective vector with this
data set and so it's time for transfer
learning
how are you back
[Applause]
all right thanks for that so
now we're all asked experts on how like
the theory of object detection and cnn's
work and we know how to get a you know
efficiently sample a data set
we're gonna basically get stuck in and
do some object detection
and see the kind of role of transfer
learning in computer vision and how it's
important in
object detection models
so
as i said we want to do this objection
and we've chosen yellow v3 because we
want to do some like real time object
detection
and
we know about
uh how to like efficiently sample some
data because annotation is expensive so
we can't just be there you know 24 7 um
labeling and taking images so
you've got some
date you want to annotate you either do
it yourself you pay for it or you make
your intern do it
and then
now you actually want to train your
model so
we have a little data set um
this is like a sub a subset of the
arthropod taxonomy data set which is
just an open source one on kaggle um if
you want to find it and this is just a
subsample of that where it's got um
seven classes of
i think it's the order of the insect um
i'm not an entomologist so i can't
remember
um so uh yeah we've brought a small data
set a couple of hundred examples of each
um each object class
which is as kind of computer vision like
modern computer vision
goes that's a pretty small data set so
if you compare that to
um like microsoft coco data set that has
got um
330 000 images with
200 000 of them labeled millions of
objects 80 object categories and it's
got you know bounding box annotations
it's got like um you can kind of see
around here kind of like the pixel
segmentation of um saying objects it's
also got like uh you know human key
points and face key points kind of loads
of stuff like that
um and so like the coco data set is also
important because it's
kind of the
it gives a lot like standardized tools
for
object detection so
kind of
any open source um object detection
framework all use probably the coco kind
of format for annotations and
things as well as
it provides the uh
like api for kind of visualizing images
um with annotations and also your api
for
getting your kind of
your
performance metrics
which are mostly used
so
before we go a quick word on the
performance metrics
some of my pitches are missing
but yeah cool so talked about iou
earlier
and so
in
object detection you're using kind of
average precision this is the kind of
most common um
kind of performance metric for comparing
models which you'll see in you know if
you look at papers doing that
and
basically the way it works is
you know when you have an image you have
multiple objects maybe so you need to
match
detections with the ground truth objects
and do that based on like the um iou
score so you basically there's like some
common
magnitude um average precision 50 so
that's with the you know matches done
based on a
you know when i have an iou greater than
0.5 that's considered a match and then
you know you can assign true positives
false positives and all that in that way
and then
you get a precision recall curve for
that and then your average precision is
uh your area under that curve which is
kind of um interpolated and computed in
this um api
so yeah the um
three we'll look at is
average precision with this iou of 1.5
also one when it's over 0.75 and then
the coco version
which is
uh you take
average precision at multiple different
ious so you kind of end up with like
average average precision um and then
also averaged over classes so it's
um
it's kind of a
little bit convoluted but it's kind of
the usual way of doing it but we'll just
focus on the
more simple ones for now
um
so
if you have your data set
and you want to
train a model to do object detection
the classic thing is if you have one
task
in one domain so say like you have a big
data set like coco you just train that
model on that and then you test it on
whatever you know day you're using test
it or deploy it
then
you know you finish that project you
move on and next week you're doing your
insects so you uh
you just train a separate model on that
and deploy on your insect pictures and
then they're just
they're separate
so if you do that with object detection
then
you download some source code for your
v3 and then you have all randomly
initialized weights and you
you just you trade on data so you can
see what happens and you think oh yeah
the
trading loss looks okay up here it looks
like it's converging to something
sensible
but then your validation and like test
average position looks pretty
questionable um
it's not doing great and you could do
things like you know you could train
this for a bit longer
you could do like high parameter
optimizations and data augmentation and
all that stuff but
you know you find it still not working
great
so
there's a kind of
transfer learning approach is
from your big task of coco you transfer
some knowledge from that first model
into a second
and so in computer vision
that's kind of uh the way it works is
you use these pre-trained ways so you
know training
these like giant cnns you need like tons
of processing power tons of data and
just tons of time
but
a lot of the um like actual
features themselves um are actually kind
of generic so in the early layers as i
kind of mentioned earlier these are
low-level features where it starts with
like edges blobs
and things like that push kind of just
generic um
image features and then that kind of
slowly builds up till you know the late
layers where you have more semi-semantic
parts potentially
which
you know that they'll be a bit more task
specific but so
what the kind of standard approach is is
you have these pre-trained weights from
usually imagenet or maybe you know
another big data set of your choosing
and then you either just use the feature
extractor
um with those weights and just keep them
as they are
so just using it as if it was like you
know a really good handcrafted feature
or you fine tune the model using just
those weight as initialization
and then
continue your
greatness in from there
so if you look at our
yolo model
so you have the basic part is this uh
the the backbone which is the darknet
mentioned earlier and then you have
these three
um
these three uh
detect like detection heads which do
your
object classification and bounding box
regression to actually turn
you know a feature map of the image into
you know here's the box is where an
object is and this is what the object is
so the kind of
the classic thing in
a computer vision is you use you know um
image net pre-trained weights in your
backbone so in this case you have
your dark net
and you load in um image net pressure
start and then continue it
and so compared to before
you end up with you know your loss curve
has improved kind of quite noticeably
and so has your um like average
precision on your validation set
so
you know
that looks a lot better
but you can go a bit further because
there obviously
detection on cocoa and detection of
insects are somewhat related so your
output of a detection model is basically
some bounding box coordinates
usually an object score and then some
classicals
but if you're detecting
people and chairs and
whatever else on coco or insects in this
data set then
you're still kind of proposing a
bounding box and some objects in the
same way it's only really
the number of classes you have and what
those semantic classes actually are that
change
so you can actually transfer
not just the backbone but essentially
every layer from the head except the
very last one where you need to change
the size of it
so
you know you can get that
not just the image features from your
pre-trained network but also some of the
the knowledge about how to propose a
kind of generic bounding box for some
arbitrary object type of thing
so
trading on that then this is a noun
green
again you see
it's it's it's the training curve is
improving you're getting slightly more
average precision with 0.5 um
and
another thing is you're just getting to
you're getting kind of uh you know you
could get away with training these for
less time like they're getting to
you know a stable point in with that
learning rate kind of more quickly so
you could cut down that training time
and that would
be very helpful when you're actually
doing your
parameter optimization like hyper amp
optimization or your data augmentation
kind of tuning
um so that's going to
with this like um
ap50 as we mentioned earlier it's kind
of like
an iou of 0.5 is actually like
that's not that good of an overlap
that's kind of like
that's a measure of is the
model getting vaguely the right object
in the right place but if you look at
more
kind of the other
um
the other
iou
uh
the other average precisions with other
ious there we go um then you know with a
0.75 that's all up to much more accurate
bounding box and then as the cocoa one
yeah that goes all the way up to like a
0.95 iu so like super accurate and
that's where you're seeing
a much bigger difference between using
just image net pre-trained weights or
using the coco ones so you're just
getting that you know you're
transferring
that knowledge of image features but
also being able to transfer
this more like refined
bounding box regression for objects
as well as benefits like you don't have
to train as long and things like that
so we end up with
can you see the bounding box very well
not really um
just some examples if you like looking
at insects um
so yeah generally if you look at this
kind of training from scratch which is
kind of just
jargon for using random initialization
in your weights um
except getting some bounding boxes but
it's kind of
you know getting
quite a few it doesn't quite know the
difference
um and again the uh
you know it's kind of quite a subtle
difference between
the image and then coco where
you know the the empirical results are
quite close
um it is going to be more like
you know you just end up with a slightly
you know slightly better
um
bounding box that kind of fits the
ground truth better and maybe there's
somewhere it's kind of missing stuff and
things like that
um
and
so i have a quick notebook
which is basically
um
just
you know
if you wanted quick and dirty just train
a model to your protection
so this is just some data set
that like the process want to have where
it's got
you know your object label and then the
image it's in and then it's kind of
bounding box coordinates
in the image and then also the image
height image width
and so yeah trying this graph of just
the
you know the train test split and
each class and you know you can do all
your classic eda you love to do because
you're
you know diligent data scientists
and then
you know one of the very important
things that i said is kind of
the cocoa annotation format because
basically whether you use like you know
any open source
detection framework like you know if you
see torch vision or if you use um
detector on or mm detection
or like any of them then
they'll pretty much all
use this by default or at least have
um
have it kind of as part of how they read
annotations so
it's basically you save them each of
your split in into like a json file
and you just have a
you know uh
which is a dictionary and then you have
your list of images you lift to a list
of object categories and then your list
of annotations
and so you're again
do a list of images yes
it's like a list of more dictionaries
um
but it's kind of
uh
the important things i think is you can
find all the stuff on the coco website
for more detail um but there's a lot of
things a lot of like quirks to it like
when you're giving the image id
then you need to do the id index from
one if you have it in zero it'll break
the um performance metrics and stuff
like that there's a lot of quirks like
this aren't documented um
and the same with um image i'd like when
you go to annotations you have id but
that's the annotation
and
a lot of this kind of stuff
but anyway
so you take your um
you take your process data where you
have
all your examples which image it's in
all the banner boxes and you can
write this
into
the cooker style json file which is just
an example of
me doing this for this and you can use
the kind of coco api to
like visualize some examples
just to you know do a sanity check to
make sure you've written your bounding
boxes correctly and you're not just
going to be training an object detector
on on garbage um another fun quirk of
the coco api is for some reason it
doesn't put object
like class labels on there so go do it
yourself um
but
then you can actually kind of use an
object detection um
framework
to actually train a model so this is for
using mmm detection which is um
just an open source model which is kind
of quite it has kind of lots of
validated um up-to-date architectures so
you can kind of
do a quick check on what performs well
you can try a few different ones
and it has them all like implemented and
validated so you have you know their
full standard kind of
optimizer settings and their data
augmentation and things like that
so you end up
this is like you write
a pi file which is your config for it
where you you know inherit from
some base model
in this case kind of the standard yellow
v3
with a particular like backbone and
particular parameters
and then you need to make some changes
for your data set so the first thing is
you change
in your bounding box you want to set how
many classes you have
so in our case we have seven insects so
i changed seven
and then we add our data in
in um
in this coco data format there are a few
other formats as well
and you can set up you know your train
test and validation sets
and as well as saying stuff like uh how
many like your batch ties on each gpu
whether you're doing it on one gpu or
many and you can also set your like
number of workers for your
pre-processing and augmentation stuff
and then
so if you wanted to change from random
weights then you actually have to
explicitly set that in the uh config to
uh
to not load in pre-training weights
which because as i said kind of
using processing weights is so
like
it's
kind of done everywhere in computer
vision at this point
and
another thing you can do is if you want
to load fully from coco models then you
can just add in a
another line to load some actual like
yellow yellow v3 weights
so you're this is only in your backbone
where you'll be loading weights for just
that part
um so then you can again you can do
stuff like you can
use the functions like browse in the
data set which lets you
there um some pictures somewhere
all right that's not working well you
could browse your data set and just see
the you know your augmented training
images again you know you've not messed
up your your annotations there and that
all makes sense
and then yeah you can um
you can just like run the model and in
this kind of
with this kind of like simple
config file you're not changing the
optimizer kind of parameters or
augmentation or anything but that is
something you can it's kind of
easily doable
um
and then
yeah once you've trained you get to
look what i've seen before where you
have your um you can check it check your
average position and your loss and
everything make sure everything's
looks great and then compare models and
yeah again just look at some lovely
examples of insects
so yeah there's two more examples here
where some
compared to the annotation sir
oh yes i guess here's a good example
where
uh
the cocoa wants managing to detect two
insects so whether
well this is like
thresholded off low lower
uh low low scoring ones as well as when
you have like non-maximal suppression
and you get over kind of like heavily
overlapping bounding boxes and things
like that
yeah
that's it that's us
so
thank you
[Applause]
also
tesco is hiring so if you're interested
in data science
computer vision as well
then come talk to us
any questions
they will be here
i will fix that one that wasn't working
um
uh how would we use detecting insects in
particular
uh we'll see like tesco if you go into a
tesco store there's cameras everywhere
so kind of
there's
dozens of use cases
question yes
so
there are many ashing techniques
uh if i understood well the question is
what uh outward is the best one
images
very quickly without having to
do a pairwise
oh yes
in principle uh the idea uh what you
suggest
so i think that a cooler approach could
be just re to run first the clustering
and then on the clustering uh do a
nursing
in order to restrict
the dataset the
sample
yeah
but
what i show
here was just
for the
sake of the presentation obviously when
we compute the hashing and
is done
by
standard libraries and
that
do in a more smart way that just
than simply
comparing
all the
[Music]
all the as i did
i hope that i answered the question
but yeah for sure
applying clustering and on the
clustering identified as similar
could be a good approach
any other question
yes
oh yes
what kind of application we are a very
new group in tesco so
those are just the experimentation we
want to understand what we can do what
uh how good could be
uh
objective direction or object
classification
uh if we are able to identify some
uh those kind of stuff so first of all
we try with this
simple setting like the coke or the
elvis
or
any kind of synthetic data set but there
could be many different possible
applications for example
identify
if a
shelf is empty or identify how many
products
there are
in a basket
or something like that
uh
yes they use computer vision but we are
not in that group
so we don't know much
oh sorry
yeah yeah yeah the notebooks will be
well well lately and
i don't know if by today but by the end
of the week there will be online
do you raise your hand
okay
cool thanks for your time
[Applause]